c'est un hélicoptère de l'armée
canadienne qui a d'abord fait la macabre
découverte jeudi en fin de journée si
corps gisant dans le fleuve
Saint-Laurent près d'une embarcation
bleu clair renversée vendredi deux
autres corps ont été repêchés au total
le fleuve aura emporté 8 personnes une
famille roumaine dont les deux enfants
en bas âge avait un passeport canadien
et une autre famille d'origine indienne
les policiers sont toujours à la
recherche d'un homme à quoi ça ce n'est
Hawkes 30 ans à qui appartenait le
bateau retrouvé on ne sait pas pour le
moment si les relier au drame
c'est un événement là qui va secouer
toute la communauté et bien entendu
comme ancien point ici de penser à ces
agents de la paix qui ont travaillé qui
ont découvert qu'en fait c'est ma carte
découverte des moments qui sont
difficiles alors s'assurer qu'ils ont
toutes les nécessaires le territoire
mohacès est un endroit reconnu pour le
passage illégal de drogue d'armes mais
aussi de trafic humain à cheval entre le
Québec l'Ontario et l'État de New York
c'est un endroit névralgique pour passer
la frontière la police de quoi ça ce
n'est a intercepté depuis janvier 80
personnes tentant de se rendre
illégalement aux États-Unis dans un
communiqué envoyé en février dernier
elle faisait état d'une augmentation du
phénomène c'est facile
certaines fois des gens d'ici
souvent des jeunes vulnérables qui ont
la peau du gain de faire de l'argent
rapidement et puis sont exploités ni
plus ni moins par les organisations
criminelles que ça soit de Montréal ou
Toronto d'Ottawa c'est des gens qui
proviennent de pays de l'hygiène haute
que le Canada et puis que il entre en
contact avec ses réseaux criminels là
qui savent à cause d'une situation
géographique ils vont être en contact
avec quelqu'un ici qui est prêt à faire
une pièce comme on dit en français
rapidement pour traverser des gens
d'ailleurs des membres de la communauté
se sont piégés
pour lutter contre la violence armée
Québec a octroyé 6 millions de dollars
sur 5 ans au service de police
mais la police avec ses 49 agents a plus
de 37 km de berges à surveiller et
souffre elle aussi de pénurie de main
d'oeuvre
l'enjeu de l'immigration illégale ne
peut pas reposer sur les épaules de sa
petite communauté dit le grand chef les
gouvernements doivent s'attaquer aux
politiques d'immigrations qui poussent
les familles à se mettre en danger
pour éviter que d'autres migrants
perdent la vie en croyant gagner la
liberté
ici Marie-José paquet como Radio-Canada
à quoi ça ce n'est